So where I think people might get the ideas,
okay,
if I'm in a relationship with my wife and she gives,
serves me dry chicken again.
Yeah.
Right.
Which is,
which is a common theme in my household.
And actually thanks to the Internet,
it's actually changed now because she's gotten thousands of people that have now
sent her how to keep the chicken moist.
So she does a great job.
But for,
for,
um,
you know,
we're talking about two decades of my life.
We're talking about dry chicken.
This is a problem.
And you know what I did?
I didn't say anything because I just would drink more water,
more water at dinner.
Yeah.
I fear that sometimes people say,
well,
you know,
what I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna run around and I'm going to tell the truth
to everyone all the time on these little things that don't matter.
Now,
my,
my actual best example that I've ever heard of this,
we had a guy in the podcast named Charlie plum.
He was a pilot in Vietnam.
He was shot down in.
Um,
and on his last mission of his deployment,
he was shot down.
He was captured,
he was in the Hanoi Hilton for six years.
This is the deal that they had amongst their roommates.
So they had roommates in a room smaller than we're in right now,
and there'd be four of them in there,
three of them in there too.
From there,
depending on what was going on,
if you did something that annoyed me,
if Jordan does something that annoys me,
we got to live together.
If you do something that annoys me,
it's my fault.
It's my fault for allowing you clip,
clip,
clip your nails together or you pick your nose a lot or you itch your head,
whatever it is that you do.
That bothers me.
It's my problem and I have to absorb it because otherwise what we have is we
have like rats in a cage that are going to know each other apart.
And I thought about that while I was reading the part of the book that was
saying,
and you actually also later in the book talk about,
Hey,
you know,
are you going to get fired over this little stupid thing?
Are you going to absorb?
And I talk about that a lot as a leader,
as a,
as a person in a relationship,
hey,
there's problems from your boss.
You absorb them and you don't pass them down to your people.
You know,
you,
you want us to stay,
work or stay late and do a bunch of crazy stuff that we don't think we should be
doing?
Cool.
My guys are going to go home.
I'm going to absorb that.
I'll get it done myself.
I'm not going to,
I'm going to absorb these problems.
Now are there some tertiary effects?
Of course are secondary effects that now my boss thinks he can get away with
that and all those things.
But I just think there's,
we have to be careful that we're not just throwing spears of truth in people's
heads on a regular basis or black truths.
They're the opposite of white lies,
right?
So black truths are truths you use to hurt other people.
So technically in the moment the statement is factual,
but the context be lies,
right?
Whereas a white lie,
it's like,
well it's a little lie,
but you're trying to support a larger truth,
not that white white lies aren't optimal.
You know,
it's better not to lie,
but sometimes the best you can manage as a white lie and then maybe that takes
pretty good.
Well,
okay,
so then in those sorts of situations you think,
well first of all,
I have some rules of thumb.
If someone does something at work annoys you.
It's like,
write it off,
man.
It's like that's once.
It's like,
what does that mean?
You're having a bad year,
having a bad day or I'm having a bad day.
It's like it doesn't mean anything.
Do it twice.
Think it's okay,
I'll just write that off.
Write that off.
It's,
that's the same issue.
It could still just be circumstance and situation three times.
Okay.
Now there might be grounds for a conversation.
You go and say,
well,
you know,
you put your feet up on my desk like a day ago,
and that was okay,
but then you did it again and then like you did it again.
And I'm thinking it actually happened three times.
Right.
So there's no denying it and perhaps that's not optimal.
And then you go for the smallest possible victory.
That's the next thing is like,
I'm not telling you that you're,
what would you say that you lack respect or that there's something wrong with
you?
What I'm asking is that if you come in my office,
it would be better for both of us if your feet stayed on the floor.
That okay.
You know,
and that's a small thing.
You're not going after the person's character,
right?
You're going after the tiny victory.
So you say to your wife,
look like I'm thrilled to death that you're cooking me dinner.
I really,
I'm serious because,
and it could be a hell of a lot worse than it is,
you know?
And,
and maybe I could be more helpful around the kitchen.
That's certainly a possibility.
But I have the got this thing with regards to chicken and maybe it's me,
you know,
but could we try for like a month to cook it differently and then we'll revisit
it and if I happen to be wrong,
like I'll shut the hell up and she might think,
okay well he is kind of useless around the kitchen and he sort of bitchy about
the chicken and all of that.
But maybe I trust him enough to admit that I made a small mistake and rectify it
and we could go along and not have the damn chicken thing hanging over our heads
until we're 80 right.
You know,
you just in your second example there you,
I,
I tell people this all the time.
So you're coming into my office and you're putting your feet on the desk.
What I'll generally do is make it my fault.
I have generally say,
Hey Jordan,
I hate to be like a nitpicker but I'm really freaked out about germs.
It's really stupid,
but I am.
And when you come in and put your feet on my desk,
it freaks me out.
Can you just do me a favor and not put your fruit in your [inaudible].
Same thing with,
you know,
with the chicken,
it's like,
Hey,
you know what?
I have a super sensitive palate.
Refined and I,
yeah.
Tested for refined,
sensitive pallet.
Fine.
Sorry,
chicken.
But,
and I just,
yeah.
Could we maybe figure out another way to cook that or,
oh,
could we try,
you know,
but I'll take the blame for,
for the situation,
rather than,
you're,
you're disrespectful and don't put your feet on my desk.
This is adopt
a more of a position of moral superiority than is absolutely necessary.